let's get into this big news ladies and
gentlemen we've got the Twitter thread
from Barry Weiss the Twitter files part
two Twitter secret blacklists I Will Not
Waste Your Time Dr J batachara charya
was arguing that covid lockdowns would
harm children he was placed on a Trends
Blacklist and also has this flag recent
abuse strike whatever that means then we
have Dan bongino who was search
blacklisted and he also had something
called a notification Spike I don't know
what that means you can see he had no
strikes but they put him on a blacklist
that look and and it says multiple
accounts Twitter blue verified not safe
for work view I wonder what spma means
Charlie Kirk do not amplify recent abuse
strike and notification Spike multiple
accounts not safe for work view
interesting
what does that mean multiple accounts
are they accusing these individuals of
personally operating multiple accounts
sounds like it but I think that that's a
bannable offense right or maybe it's
because he's got like you know Turning
Point USA is his organization so he's in
charge of several different accounts
Twitter denied that they Shadow banned
people they said that they didn't do it
they certainly didn't do it on on
ideology but then the funny thing is you
get this story first definitely dot
Twitter insists it's not Shadow Banning
conservatives and then I think is this
one weird here Twitter appears to have
fixed Shadow ban of prominent
Republicans like RNC chair and Trump
Junior spokesman so that was July 25th
2018 and then this story this was July
27 2018 saying they're not they're not
doing it they're not doing it it was
updated in May uh 2021 I wonder why so
this is uh we all knew but once again
Twitter files are delivering hard proof
conservatives are being banned Shadow
banned manipulated de-amplified
de-boosted whatever and the the stories
currently developing Barry y says this
is funny they said they don't Shadow ban
everybody they do visibility filtering
they call it VF refers to the ability to
limit the scope of a particular tweets
or individuals discoverability to block
select users posts from ever appearing
on the trending page and from inclusion
and hashtag searches all without people
knowing I have to wonder
they did the sedan bongino
he uses Twitter as a business for his
business is this a breach of contract if
I enter into a contract with you and you
secretly apply restrictions against me
are they breaching their contract or is
the argument going to be no no the terms
of service say that we can do all of
these things to you
I'm not familiar with the terms enough I
would imagine
because it's a free to use service that
you really don't have any recourse to
sue them if they're screwing with you
but I don't know I don't know what the
promise was check this out they this is
where it starts getting crazy quote we
control visibility quite a bit and we
control the amplification of your
content quite a bit and normal people do
not know how much we do how much we do
one Twitter engineer told us two
additional employees confirmed the group
that decided whether to limit the reach
of certain users was the Strategic
response team global escalation team or
Sr SRT get it often handled the 200
cases per day but there existed a level
Beyond official ticketing beyond the
rank and file moderators following the
company's policy on paper that is the
site Integrity policy policy escalation
support known as sip PES the secret
group included head of legal policy head
of legal policy and Trust for jagade the
global head of trust and safety Joel
Roth subsequent CEOs Jack Dorsey and pop
Agarwal and others it's where the
biggest most politically sensitive
decisions got made think High follower
count controversial another Twitter
employee told us told us for these there
would be no ticket or anything take a
look at this Libs of tick tock it says
do not take action on user without
consulting the s-i-p-p-e-s
really really interesting stuff they
mentioned that rychic had been suspended
several times you can see Libs Libs of
tick tock has a recent abuse strike
notification Spike and his Trend
blacklisted two strikes high profile it
says multiple accounts not safe for work
View
so you know how much of uh how much of
this is just kind of like yeah okay we
know
uh having the receipts here I think is
absolutely important I I think there's
going to be a bigger implications here
because it wasn't just these few
accounts that we mentioned here Barry
Weiss in uh the tread number 12
specifically documents and and says how
there was 20 cases a day of individuals
being individually targeted and attacked
as Twitter was going on and publicly
saying that we were absolutely not
Shadow Banning the corporate media was
regurgitating their talking points you
could see I just retweeted uh the
official Twitter account from 2018 they
said quote people are asking us if we
Shadow ban we don't read more to get all
the facts the fact they're not they're
not facts here again this is an official
Twitter account uh tweeting this a
couple years ago gaslighting people
lying to people as they were
manipulating our social discourse and we
know that when they do this they could
decide and determine not only the
outcome of Elections but have huge huge
major effects on society with the power
to essentially control people's minds
this is this is next level stuff I want
to I want to talk later about uh
Brittany Greiner and uh Paul Paul Wellen
is his name right Paul Whalen am I
getting it wrong yes uh there's um this
article from Jordan Shack till I think
it is
uh outlining how the the Biden
Administration intentionally ignored
this guy and opted for Brittany Greiner
and even NBC initially reported I think
it was nbcu
that Russia said you can have one or the
other not both and so Obama was like
give us the basketball player showing
that he doesn't care about our Marines
or the people who are who are overseas
or whatever he had the option he didn't
take it
I saw that and I just felt like I need
to stress to everybody
Joe Biden does not represent you he does
not represent any of us in this room
he does not represent the Marines or the
Army he represents his cult
the president
the Democrats in the Senate and Congress
are cult members
you do not exist to them
there was no consideration for a former
Marine when they were doing a prisoner
swap with The Merchant of death an arms
dealer because Joe Biden said
why would I care about that guy I want
you to think about it this way
right now in this country what's
happening let's say that um
you uh there's a hostage situation
and you're outside and the the the
hostage taker says I'll only release one
person your daughter or John Smith and
you're like who's John Smith in the
black well he's a decorated war hero he
saved a box full of puppies the other
day give me my daughter
my point is Joe Biden when he looks at
the potential of this he doesn't think
about the American people he thinks
about his cult and his ideology and what
earns him those points with his crowd he
is not representing the United States of
America I mentioned this back during the
coveted lockdowns when Florida was not
locked down when South Dakota was not
locked down and other conservative
states were not locked down and Joe
Biden came out and said we are locking
down for these reasons and we're gonna
have to do this that or otherwise and
I'm like well who's he talking to he
keeps tweeting at me to tell me to get
my vaccine get a vaccine that's not even
a doctor yeah he's not talking to you
he's not tweeting Abby you're right he's
just talking about and I'm reading it
like no no no not a doctor what I'm
saying is when Joe Biden came out and
said everyone we need to do these things
he wasn't talking to any of us in this
room or any of you watching
they don't see us as part of the same
country as them I think that's just a
reality and this is exemplified just so
hilariously this is the issue I have
with conservatives Time Magazine chooses
zelenski and what do conservatives do
they go I can't believe Time Magazine
chose zelenski as person of the year
it's like first of all why would you
read Time Magazine they're the ones who
published that article about fortifying
the election they don't have any real
circulation anymore they're not
culturally relevant but conservatives
view the left as culturally relevant and
as the as the the epicenter of America
and American culture for some reason and
the left views them as creepy weirdos
have nothing to do with what this
country is doing
well and I think this is how we're
different like this is where I actually
get some pushback from my followers if
I'm America First that means that I want
to put every American first even the
commies even people that disagree with
me because I value uh upholding my
citizens rights and so even with
Brittany you know I was getting pushed
back from saying it yes we do need to
secure her Freedom even if she broke
Russian law even if she doesn't stand
for the flag or doesn't stand for our
freedoms and freedom of speech and even
when some people are saying you know to
leave cities and to leave California
behind and they chose this and let them
suffer the consequences of their votes
uh no I I don't think that's an America
First perspective we need to be fighting
for Freedom everywhere now with that
being said does does that mean that I
think that we should trade The Merchant
of death and and Russian arms dealer
while the very country Russian Putin are
invading Ukraine all I can see from this
is I think there's a very real
possibility that through his connections
with his freedom now we could see Putin
uh gaining even more arms to use against
Ukraine which what does that mean from
us that means that we are going to be
sending another 74 billion dollars to
Ukraine to solve the problem that was
just exacerbated by our very president
and that's kind of where my head is at
in this and I say not another dime for
Ukraine I was already at if we're
securing Ukraine's border while we're
not securing ours why should we be
sending them any money but the the fact
of the matter is the United States is
creating a problem while also trying to
be the solution and the only people that
are suffering from this or are us
I met a guy he was I think he was a
captain in the in the Army I think I
can't remember I don't know how the
ranking stuff works but he said he
retired he was planning on uh staying in
until he was too old he wanted to be you
know a careerist or you know first full
career and then he's in his mid-30s and
he said he was resigning his Commission
because of the wokeness that's happening
in the military
and so I see that and I'm and I'll say
it you know they're shutting down
prisons they're releasing criminals
crime is rampant and the politicians
keep like the Democrats in these cities
keep doing the same thing and I'm like
isn't it obvious at this point it's
because you are not a part of what they
are doing when they say our democracy
replace when they say our democracy
replace that with cult and then remember
that you're not a part of their cult so
when Joe Biden comes out and says these
far-right extremists are a threat to our
cult then you need to understand what
he's really saying he's not talking
about the United States he's talking
about something that excludes you
specifically yeah the United States is a
plural the United States are a thing
it's a bunch of states that are united
we are united and if if someone in the
federal government is trying to override
that and act like they're the one that
resembles the you the States United then
they're failing thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time